although search for they are
interrelated but I will relate them
because beginning again to the key
issues of the question let's begin with
a question a tough one what is modernity
well modern it is whatever is now if you
define modernity as now that whatever is
now is modern and there is not you know
this is this is videos if a studios but
but actually is the only really good way
because theories of modernization were
predicated a notion of precisely modern
economies and then underdeveloped
economies and this isn't because they're
not yet modern and then came the Marxist
economics is it no no they are not the
traditionally underdeveloped
they have been they have done the
development itself is a product of
capitalist modernity so you cannot
simply say that you have the developed
societies in Europe and then you have
the underdeveloped in Latin America and
the question is only how they
underdeveloped other American economies
somehow go through the same process of
development is this the wrong way of
look in modernity obviously modernity
it's a temporal category it was the
debates in the 16th century simmered the
modern seconds the I ancients and since
then has been a way for some people
having a project of change of
transformation naming those who were not
with them reactionary today with a
progressive and traditionalism and is
the whole philosophy of time that has
constituted the kind of the projection
what could possess the hair mask calls a
project of modernity in the process we
know that this is related to or
consulate say let's put 15th century as
there is the kind of turning point and
you have together the immersion of
Protestant Reformation and if you follow
Max Weber you know that it has a lot to
do with modernity the immersion of the
mother individual mother capitalism
vocational ethic but then other people
have pointed how Protestantism is the
Puritan revolution is intimately linked
with democracy and the revolution of the
saints our people have linked it to
science so you have the immersion of our
Protestantism you have the emergence of
the modern scientific revolution you
have the emergence of modern states
territorial stated eventually become
what we recognize is the modern
democratic state and then you have also
the the age of discoveries and the
emergence of a globalized and we know
that the system of even there was
valiant system of states that fight with
one another but then they have a
pressure of global colonialism together
and how at the same time you have a
separation of rational states you have a
globalization of capitalism going on
together so it has to do with science it
has to do with the states do with
markets is an Englishman with
individualism those are the four
fundamental things having to do with
modernity but then those things even
from the 15th century to 2010 radically
all the time what is the modern form of
modernist stay with when we talk of
democracy today we say well is liberal
democracy but in the 19th century
liberalism and democracy were topos
leaders weren t Democrats and Democrats
were anti-liberal
it took a whole process of
transformation to fuse the two thing and
we think to the idea to be a modern
state means rule of law
liberalism and democracy but precisely
the Prussian state was a rule of royal
state but neither liberal nor democratic
it was Madame but it had neither liberal
nor democracy America was the only one
that was the three the French were
Democrats but not liberals and so on and
the British were living but not
Democrats so you have and you disagree
about individualism we know from
substellar of course the importance of
the expressive romantic self-expression
is central to the category of the mother
individual but this emerge precisely is
what was called a reactionary
anti-modern against the utilitarian
individualism but today we understand
that mother individualism is a few
of utilitarian self-interest rational
calculation then self experimenting self
expressive so it takes all this kind of
process in every context what would you
characterize as a modern economy radical
new liberal market economy or state
regulated control economy welfare state
or those are ideological issues which
economies more modern the neoliberal
American economy or the Scandinavian
welfare state if a process even on this
point you have all kinds of variations
today Chinese capitalism I was mentioned
before has all the characteristics of
what Max Weber will define as non
rational man and modern capitalism
it says kinship capitalism has state
capitalism and has gambling there are
three things that he defines as
irrational capitalism but is it
perfectly rational affective capitalism
in the global market I can tell you so
so we have yes you could say that it is
the globalization of science and
technology is the globalization of of
market exchanges Anisa globalization of
ideas of our state's regulation kind of
made up of cities and subjects and so on
and public sphere so this is what what
what Taylor calls the horizontal
societies of individuals gathering
together for mutual benefit so rather
hierarchical systems and then it has to
it individualism and we could say the
practically everywhere in the world very
few people would challenge the notion
that the self-evident truths life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness and
you could add here is interesting that
the American Revolution is liberty the
pursuit of happiness has no solidarity
fraternity well of course
Liberty Goleta fraternity we have
liberty equality in a period of
happiness they have liberty equality and
fraternity solidarity those are two
modern what are modern but they have
different elements in it and so these
principles are gender equality
nobody today there's a slavery who will
defend to the ism
but in nobody but we have more slavery
today this one we did in the past in
terms of the actual operation so we
formally we have no slaves anymore
but as labor is the system and says that
you have millions of people that
basically are totally under systems that
that give them no freedom gender
equality well today you have if you ask
Muslim women 90 percent will tell you
that Islam is the perfect religion
precisely because it gives the preferred
religion for gender equality
no liberated feminists in the West boo
can you say Islam the religion of gender
equality well that's what Muslim women
saying you have to take it seriously so
we are in in a context in which even
when we use the same concept the same
words they mean very different things in
different contexts so we have democracy
yes but Indian democracy very different
from the French from the American and so
on so there has been a globalization of
certain structures but they're still
very much connected with also all kinds
of not only different institutional
arrangements because this is very very
easy to differentiate parable different
cultural substantive feeling what will
be the formal structures